riding wasn't always faceless lines and
abstract symmetry originally it was a
bunch of pictures come see how it all
started LaFrance 17,000 years ago it's
cold out and getting colder possibly
dangerous to this maybe France and this
may be the history of writing but
there's nothing for you here until you
take shelter in a nearby cave and see
how creative some of your ancestors
really were drawing on their enlarging
brains and a long prehistory of building
ever more complex tools these early
artists took to etching and painting
beautiful visual representations of the
animals around them these aren't words
they're not stories they're pictures
early pictures like these start to
become very routine not necessarily
depicting the world but marking and
standing for things a place to hunt a
place to eat
these are pictographs the story gets
sketchy here but it's important to
notice that pictographic symbols like
these petroglyphs rock carvings weren't
words they weren't language but they
became more than personal and communal
artistic expressions they became regular
and repeatable possibly mapping to
specific things and for that these
pictographs earned themselves the fancy
label of proto
writing many pictographs have an
intuitive give away quality they look
like drawings of the things they
represent draw me a human easy draw me a
horse sure a river there it is but how
do you clearly and simply draw less
tangible ideas like playing around or
taking it easy or don't even think about
it
uh-oh watch out for this major moment in
the history of writing meat metonymy
this principled fellow lets you
represent a general nebulous idea with
the related pictogram or part of a
pictogram or a pictogram combo that's
pretty specific and obvious ancient
stick human is a regular old pictogram
if you cut off sticks legs you can get
across the
general idea what walking removing what
about a man leaning against a tree
what's the idea here taking it easy
resting these are ideographs symbols for
ideas and concepts in some sense all of
these drawings express ideas the concept
of a horse concept of a human so they're
all ideograph ik but with a little
imagination and a lot of time extended
ideographs let you cut and combine basic
pictographs to be far more expressive
and abstract just when you're ready to
grab that chisel and get your
pictographic and ideographic carving on
someone more inventive than you comes
along your pictures and ideas aren't
enough for her gone are the old cave
days the world outside is changing and
she needs words words my friend
you